bonsoir bonsoir
kelly a 28 ans dont vous êtes la fille
de lino ventura et vous publié chez
robert laffont un livre qui s'appelle
lino tout simplement
[Musique]
voilà lino tout simplement souvenirs
d'enfance et recettes de famille alors
c'est à la fois une lettre à votre père
lino ventura pour lui dire qu'il vous
manque et puis qu'il vous manque lui et
sa cuisine vous dites que de souvenirs
d'avec mon père qui n'est pas une vague
odeur de persillade d'huile d'olive et
de tomates fraîches
c'est vrai c'est un c'était tout papa ça
alors voilà vous parlez de votre père
vous parlez de vous parler de votre
grand mère grand mère ça se dit non en
italien non non non oui mais voilà il
s'appelait louis sam et bloup lennon a
alors avec elle lui lino parlait
toujours italien est avec vous jamais en
fait n'ont jamais ça c'est une chose que
j'ai jamais comprises mais peut-être que
j'ai un peu analysé c'est à dire que il
voulait vraiment lui qui avait tellement
souffert de l'intégration je pense qu'il
voulait que nous on soit vraiment
intégré donc pas d'italien oui un peu
comme un un peu comme la mère de france
d'enracinement c'est marrant tout à fait
ça cette volonté comme ça d'intégration
c'est moins le cas maintenant
alors elle avait sa langue à l sept noms
que comment elle disait buckingham le
palais de buckingham elle c'est lé
palais des boues jindam voilà alors
c'était oui évidemment il est même
dégaine j'espère les films de reagan the
jester voilà alors était très possessive
1 et chaque fois que votre père lino
ventura partait faire un film de
gangsters l alumine et j'ai pas une
crise une maladie très grave quoi oui
c'était toujours terriblement pathétique
c'est la commedia dell'arte à la maison
soit ça à l'aide d'un simple migraine à
la crise cardiaque et c'était toujours
quelque chose de terrible parce que papa
y croyez vraiment à les deux trucs
qu'elle supportait pas donc c'était
quand il faisait des films de gansters
et puis quand il prenait l'avion aussi à
linselles supporter alors elle était
d'une possessivité je dirais naturel
quand on connaît ses origines parmesane
et puis aussi le le fait que son mari
donc le père de lino les ai abandonnés
très jeune oui c'est vrai que ça a été
une épreuve très très difficile et papa
l'a très mal vécu enfin il ne m'en a
jamais parlé mais je crois qu'ils en
avions dû beaucoup beaucoup à cet homme
est en fait il est arrivé en france à 7
ans avec sa mère il a commencé à
travailler à 7 ans il a eu cet accident
deux triporteurs à 9 ans et
comme la police française comme il
n'avait pas de papiers l'accompagnèrent
en italie et là il a été levé par clélia
ouais alors de ces épreuves lino ventura
tirera sa morale et deux maîtres mots
qui sont dignité et respect alors il
était incroyable c'est une aventure à
parce qu'il était comme ça quoi c'est à
dire que par exemple il fait la cuisine
on va en parler il laissait jamais une
cuisine salle quoi il nettoyait la
cuisine quand il avait fini vous
continuez dans un hôtel il nettoyait la
baignoire avant de partir complètement
des principes qu'ils avaient
[Musique]
jamais il en est d'allonger à ces très
violents alors vous raconter tous ses
traits c'est très intéressant parce que
c'est vu vraiment de l'oeil delà de la
petite fille quoi donc par exemple vous
raconterez quand vous habitiez au parc
de montretout ce que vous appelez la
salle des tortures que tous les gens qui
venaient présenter des scripts à lino
ventura est passé dans ce bureau et ils
discutent et où il posait des questions
c'est insupportable pour les scénaristes
vont les réalisateurs les producteurs et
people man 2 pourquoi il dit ça
non mais je comprends pas parce que
norbert sa dame raconte oui mais
pourquoi il dit ça parce que moi dans ma
petite tête de par besoin faut que je
comprenne
alors il discutait de tout mais quand il
avait une fois qu'ils avaient acceptée
et quand il commençait à tourner après
il faisait plus rien quoi d'ailleurs
tout le monde avait à être qu'en france
at on arrêté il a été discuté oui non
mais c'est vrai que tout ce que vous
dites ça explique très bien le
personnage vous raconter les déjeuners
avec demandant cette dans cette maison
alors vous vous étiez obligés de faire
tout paris en mobylette pour aller
chercher
les ingrédients ah oui pour aller
chercher jambon là le pain la femme ont
toutes été la viande railleur
c'était c'était un périple et alors ils
recevaient beaucoup de gens et un soir
vous surprenez une discussion entre
entre jacques brel et votre père vous
êtes là peut-être un petit peu katché et
brel dia votre père en fin de compte
c'est quoi une femme pour toi et lino
répond c'est un homme qui pleure de
temps en temps oui et ça ça m'a beaucoup
marqué moi ça m'a en tant que femme je
dis pas d'accord alors on a le droit de
pleurer c'est vrai que des hommes et on
a aussi
alors vous raconter les vacances au cap
ferret dans cette maison de crainte d'or
la pétanque il est très mauvais joueur
aulas un peu comme ça j'aurais dû
montrer qui c'est raoul aux quatre coins
de paris qu' on va le retrouver
et puis alors les vacances dans la
maison d'anjou parce que pendant la
guerre ce que je savais pas c'est que
votre père est obligé de se cacher parce
qu'il est italien donc évidemment il
était chef qu'ailleurs parce qu'il était
recherché par la police française il
était recherché par les allemands et
était recherché par les italiens parce
qu'ils étaient déserteurs
il a fait tout un périple pour finir à
barra s'est passé on joue donc c'est là
et après la guerre était là bas il a
racheté la maison ils ont arrangé et
donc vous raconter les vacances d'été
là-bas visite c'était très difficile
d'éviter la cuisine parce que le matin
quand on se lever pour aller à la
piscine fallait éviter la cuisine parce
que lui tu es déjà installés et
réquisitionné toute la famille pour
faire les pour faire des plats quoi un
petit peu mais même si nous ont
réquisitionné pas si vous voulez on
était de toute façon réveillé par le
bruit du couteau
forcément la grasse matinée ne suis pas
possible arrivée devant la grande
épreuve du vin le vin était servir aux
carafes de 6 litres j'ai une espèce
d'examen de passage parce qu'il fallait
être capable de tenir la carafe de 6
litres à bout de bras oui et puis je
peux vous dire que c'était pas évident
parce que vu les têtes que j'ai vu faire
ça ou une table et 18 personnes ce n'est
pas évident quand même
vous regrettez de ne pas lui avoir plus
parler ah oui énormément en tant que
femmes
d aller vite c'était c'était difficile
de lui parler parce que c'était un
silencieux oui c'était quelqu'un
oui c'est pas c'est ptet pas quelqu'un
d'un abord facile mais comme tous les
pères je crois vous et lui parler ce
soir on va faire l'interview 10dans
gamine
disons gamine t'aurais pas voulu être la
fille de gaza en moins non
il ya un acteur aujourd'hui qui fait
penser à moi
aucun
il paraît que tous les jeunes
connaissent les tontons flingueurs
parker ça te rend fier
non pas particulièrement tu touches des
sous sur le dvd qui sort tout pas non
mais sur le lino
[Applaudissements]
sur le linoléum clélia alain d'accord là
didon gamine tu m'en veux d'avoir appelé
clélia ah non désolé j'étais bourré
non il a mis huit jours
j'étais pas inscrite dans le calendrier
ça existait pas oui alors il a dit bon
bah je reviendrai plus tard et ça s'est
passé oui pendant cinq jours j'ai bougé
pas eu tenons bien gamine est ce que tu
sais faire les pattes maintenant mais
comment ça j'en suis fier tu as peur tu
me ressembles en vieillissant non du
tout au contraire
il ya des choses que tu aurais même dire
plein sur les hommes sur la vie sur
plein de questionnements surtout
pourquoi tu me parlais pas
parce que tu étais pas facile
lisant gamine je ne fais pas chier de
devoir me parlait à travers dix ans
j'aurais adoré pas femme parle comme ça
en a l'air je veux être ton père
elia ventura lino tout simplement mais
j'ai encore la forme pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de in a l'habitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux